come over here please
I'm gonna get that knife off you sir
okay
any other weapons on you
okay come over here please
nothing else on you
phones
um what's that bridge in your pockets
what's your name sir what's that what's
your name Sir Samuel no what are you
saying about caucus do you have any
other weapons on you please don't reach
in your pockets just let me
we're out here because there is
supposedly people back
how many have people in the truck
how many other people are in the truck
well I just want to know who's inside
the truck right now so that way I know
who else we're dealing with here
or else I'm going to call everybody out
as you can see it's a pretty serious
deal here sir
what is your name
Samuel what
I'm asking for your name
sir
what is your name
Samuel what
yeah
you have to identify yourself you
understand that right yeah Samuel
Bateman
I don't understand but
what are you doing
we're trying to make sure I just got
here explain to me what's going on
yeah that's right you're being videoed
as well yeah okay
um
stuff
let's run okay
where's your date of birth sir
okay
all right sir turn up one minute
put your hands behind you put your hands
behind your back
put your hands behind your back
let's not do this right now huh you were
being detained until you identify
yourself do I have to tell my name yes
you have to identify yourself you are
being detained for a crime
we're still putting you in handcuffs
just stick tight
don't do that yeah
oh
everyone's buckled in
Arizona then
between the back of the truck
yeah we're just going to identify you
figure out what's going on we'll go from
there the reason I'm detaining you is
because you fail to identify yourself
when I ask
okay I did I said Samuel Bateman
yeah what about date of birth
that would have worked too
you've been back so I can lock this in
dude well I need to know cooperate there
Sammy what's your date of birth
control what is it
[Music]
foreign
can you help me out here a little bit
can you move your wrist so I can help
you out here
can you rotate this way and I'll adjust
those for you
lots of Bateman Boy Adam Tom Edward Mary
Adam norov
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
guys
foreign
[Music]
that makes me a little nervous so that's
why you're in handcuffs as soon as we
check everything out and you came back
you identified yourself with me I'll
take you out of handcuffs and we'll be
all good okay I don't know what DPS has
going on with you we just simply got
called as backup units for whatever you
have going on with them okay so once I
get a chance I'll go talk to that
sergeant and we'll confer about what's
going on here and what we have going on
and I will be more than happy to keep
you informed and enlightened about
everything that we're doing like I said
when I identify my try to identify you
and you didn't want to identify yourself
I went through the table when I went to
the team he stood up on us okay
settle down
okay
[Music]
Sam give me a second
let's go
I want to listen this left one okay Sam
what I'm looking at after discussing
that with that Sergeant so
it's really hard I'm always there right
now okay
if you want to come stand up really
quick this way put your right foot in
first
so uh child endangerment
yeah Sam can you get your other foot in
there
foreign
can you sit in there please
it's not the most helpful thing on
YouTube
fiberglass
plastic twist my room I'm kind of bulky
twist move
okay
bring your foot out
I'm just saying my arm here yeah you
want to swing your hind end in there
and then pop around does that work
I don't think that's gonna work there
sir
yeah
let's go this way
what's that can you put your foot back
in there you're just gonna have to
wiggle in
[Music]
let me talk to some gentleman figures
what's going on okay
there you go I see this puzzle here
really quick
[Music]
can you go across
all right don't go on face first just
hang on
what's up
okay hey Holland
I'm gonna get your boots up here okay
what do we got
yeah for sure
that's all right
yeah you got bigger shoulders here
okay there you go okay just bring that
arm down here here let me adjust this
one here
yeah yeah just want to put doubles on
them
just just double it up yeah yeah double
them up hey give me one second Sam okay
I know you're not gonna
okay can you bring us on back here this
way
should have a little bit more room for
you here
a little bit better
awesome awesome let's get it double
locked and then if you can take a seat
for us I'd appreciate it we'll get the
AC turned on for you all right here same
one second sir give me one second
all right go ahead now
Sam it'd be easier if you sat down and
then twisted your butt in and I guess
that works
all right watch your feet
[Music]
there's fingers at the intersection
there was fingers there's people in the
dress it sounds like someone's in there
yes
thank you
[Music]
open the driver's side door
foreign
[Music]
ma'am step out of the car
foreign
people back here
what about in the trailer
there's no one else in the vehicle
there's no one in the bed of the truck
and there's no one in the trailer
let's get everyone out of there come on
out
do you guys have IDs
no
we'll press our head back there hey hey
okay start walking back there they don't
need to go on a handcuffs we just need
to get them out of here
okay
follow us back here
[Music]
we'll go from there
from there this is the police we're
gonna be opening the door
I want your hands hit me above your head
do not you will suffer the consequences
again this is the police
foreign
earlier and see them
let's see your hands behind the curtain
okay keep your hands up for me go and
walk out towards me okay try not to slip
all right
just keep walking
is there anybody else inside the trailer
no perfect
thank you guys just went back there with
your siblings okay
going right back down with them okay
thank you so much
[Applause]
okay
foreign
[Music]
oh
you don't know her
no I was just wondering if you knew her
they do the same thing
no they don't try to hide it though they
just
well I mean we walk around
we walk around with cameras on all the
time so we're used to it
hanging in there
I wish it was Friday but it's not
are you guys all sisters
but not actual assistant
is there any of you that are actual
sisters
the one in the brown and you are sisters
okay
to the blue our sisters okay
I figured you guys were all tightly knit
I just didn't know the actual dynamics
of the the family unit here
has someone explained you guys our
concerns and
and why you guys
so someone called in said they saw kids
coming in and out of a trailer that in
by itself kind of dangerous right
driving down the road with kids in the
trailer and then somebody else one of
the aides saw fingers poking out of the
trailer
so now
I get that but the concern for the
danger of people in the car now you got
to realize
the whole country we have you know
smuggling of kids smuggling of
immigrants smuggling of all types of
stuff right so extremely suspicious
activity so when we go to stop you guys
and then um
I don't know what is he to you guys is
he anybody's actual father
yeah the one in the car
he's somebody's father so whoever his
father is he comes out comes over
um he's gonna start refusing to identify
himself while we're trying to conduct a
traffic stop so things are starting to
escalate until we know exactly what's
going on
now we have to build them up
of you know is there a probable cause
for any type of arrest on him for any of
the activities that was going on here
and then we have I think you guys are
over 18 you just know one of you you are
both of you so we have two adults and
then we have several kids so now we got
to decide are we just gonna let him out
of the car you guys all jump in and go
on your married way or are we having to
call parents to try to figure out how
we're gonna get him somewhere so that's
what's taking so long they're trying to
figure out these
these circumstances so you have uh DPS
who's the main investigator here and
then you had County because that's who
got the call originally and then you
have PD because it you guys are here in
the city so that's why we all showed up
and it sounded a lot more serious to
begin with than once we de-escalate
everything we start talking to people we
start getting information we start
figuring stuff out that's where we're at
right now so DPS who's handling the
investigation is making their phone
calls to try to decide what the outcome
of this is going to be and that's where
we stand right now
so used to
I mean
so this has nothing to do with you guys
your religion your beliefs anything of
that nature all has to do with the fact
that kids are in and out of a trailer
in Flagstaff Arizona
but until we get information it's hard
for us to give you guys back information
right so until we have a couple few
conversations with with the kids and it
doesn't help that whoever's father that
is absolutely doesn't want to talk to us
at all so that even eliminates more of
like where you going where you're coming
from like are we all allowed to be in
the same car like what's going on here
so again like I said nothing to do with
your beliefs religion anything of that
nature it all has to do with the
suspicious nature of what was going on
and then when we do open doors and kids
start popping out of trailers we're like
okay what do we have going on here so
again it may become a practice where you
guys are from that's not common practice
in Flagstaff
okay did you just not have enough room
for everyone in all the other vehicles
in and by itself is not against the law
however there is a danger aspect to it I
mean how many times do trailers get
flung off the road or pop tires or
you know whatever the case may be
and like I said with DPS these guys deal
with like I said actual child sex
trafficking actual immigration
trafficking drug trafficking you know
all the all these stuff that are
concerns all across the nation and again
you guys may get frustrated because
we're not providing you any information
but it's because we don't have all the
information together ourselves I just
came over here because I saw you wave
and I wanted to see if there was some
other aspect over there that we needed
to go look at and that's why I came over
and asked you but then I also understand
your frustration of not knowing what's
going on well I don't really even know
what's going on because I'm a supervisor
for PD not for DPS so I'm just kind of
piecing it together by what I'm
overhearing everyone and what the
original call came out to us and you
know just
unfortunately when people don't
do what
is expected by police officers it
heightens us so a normal traffic stop
you roll down your window you give your
driver's license you say I'm coming from
here going to there that's our everyday
interaction when we stop cars
but when we get drivers just popping out
of cars and then closing the door and
then no one else saying anything that's
not normal behavior that we see
so when that normal behavior doesn't
happen and heightens are
suspicion of what's going on so again we
like to explain to everybody what's
going on but sometimes we have to get a
little more of the information to have
that ability to do that for you well
we're sorry but
a bunch of cops or any of that
again I get it probably
I get it but sometimes by doing that you
delay
the outcome yeah
the outcome may be he gets out of the
car he gets taped off the handcuffs you
guys get back in your car in your
driveway that may happen it may happen
that he goes to jail for child neglect
that may happen as well and then we have
to figure out what we're gonna do with
all of you guys so there's a lot of
outcomes that can come of this but when
no one wants to cooperate and tell us
what's going on that delays our ability
to make those decisions you know if we
just simply pulled him out and he's like
yeah I'm so-and-so these are all church
members and family members we're all
going to a birthday party at Chuck E
cheese
and and you guys all come out and say
yeah I'm so-and-so and this is what
we're doing and if everyone's on the
same page we've already been out here
right
but
Samuel doesn't want to talk to us I
don't know what your conversation was
with these guys but you know if everyone
shuts down on us then we do have to do
that investigation what I was telling
you earlier about all the different
types of smuggling going on we got to
kind of figure out where you guys come
from and what your relationship is with
the police there I don't know
we're just lonely Flagstaff police
officers and
we're backing these guys up trying to
help them out again like I said I saw
you waving and to me that's a clue
sometimes that someone might be sitting
over there
that's with you guys and then I would go
over there and talk to that person is
what I would have done
so that's where we're at right now I was
trying to decision making time
yeah I know that's what I think
well let's see if chicconi wants us to
go down that path because it sounds like
we made you so everyone go
oh one of them
yeah they're